[Music]
due to the recent regulatory
developments we observed that companies
have mostly document management related
operations and we have begun to produce
solutions to decrease the operational
costs of these companies and to increase
customer satisfaction with IBM data gap
by using the OCR and ICR engines we have
achieved success especially reading
handwritten and forms with numbered
content thanks to the interaction design
of this which we also have in our
company by also ensuring to make forms
readable by data cap we achieved
automatic reading and automatic reading
rates of around 90 percent this has led
to factors such as increased
productivity reduced operational costs
on our own with these solutions for us
IBM data cap came across exactly what we
want as a scanning data processing
platform because it can also provide us
the opportunity to use our over 10,000
staff operations like mobile recognition
and mass scanning when we compare
operational costs after using IBM data
cap we achieve a gain of 80 percent
compared to manual operations so we
could observe that a document processed
in 20 minutes rather than a hundred
minutes but on the other hand it offered
us a structure that helps make it
compatible with the regulatory issues in
the processes such as if there is a
signature or if the document is
incomplete or complete thanks to this we
have reduced our operational costs even
further than the scope of ECM strategies
after making the capture site completely
ready with IBM data cap we aim to
produce sectoral solutions in this area
public finance and energy are the
sectors in which we
only operate in these areas we aim to
offer solutions that are specific to
these business areas on the IBM data
kept platform
[Music]
you